this video is sponsored by curiosity
stream watch over 2400 documentaries
free for 31 days with a link in the
description south of San Francisco in
Menlo Park the heart of Silicon Valley
lie a series of unremarkable offices
they have creative names like building
57 building 40 and wait for it none
other than the Employment Development
Department there's a plan though to turn
this 59 acre office park into a more or
less fully self-contained city called
Willow Village it'll have a grocery
store pharmacy retail stores playgrounds
hotel rooms a community center and 1,500
housing units oh and one more thing
it's 100% owned by everyone's favorite
company no not Equifax not Comcast or
Enron worse Facebook in just a few years
Facebook employees will be able to work
eat play shop and now sleep all without
leaving the property of the world's most
trustworthy company Google meanwhile
plans to build over 10,000 homes in
Mountain View and Apple just finished
the sixth most expensive building in the
world behind Singapore's famous Marina
Bay Sands as companies expand their
physical presence the line between
public and private is being blurred and
local governments find themselves not
governing but being governed by more
powerful corporations and it all stems
from one simple economic problem
College majors are generally fairly
constant about the same percentage of
students choose physics or psychology or
English from one year to the next
generally up until 2008 the financial
crisis had an immediate and so far it
seems permanent effect on colleges when
the Sun is out and jobs are abundant
like right now the relative value of
more education is lower your goal is to
get employed as fast as possible and
ride the wave when times are tough the
opportunity cost is much lower it's
harder to get a job keep it or get
promoted so you do the opposite go back
to school and pick the most marketable
major available and that's exactly what
happened the Great Recession changed the
entire purpose of Education the number
one reason people chose to go to college
in 2006 was to learn more about the
things that interest me in 2009 it was
to get a better job and has stayed that
way ever since first students left the
humanities in the ten years after the
recession US English degrees chopped 22%
education 19% and philosophy or
religious studies 15 meanwhile
health-related degrees have doubled
biological and biomedical sciences have
increased 61% and engineering 60%
computer science specifically has
absolutely exploded it's not hard to see
why if you find yourself getting
mediocre grades often missing class and
with totally unremarkable skills
congratulations as an average US
computer programmer you can expect to
make fifty to fifty five thousand
dollars a year right out of college no
experience or graduate degree required
in other words to earn more than 64
percent of the country all you need to
do is stay in school for one thousand
four hundred and sixty days if you keep
doing average work don't go back to
school but manage to keep this up for a
few more years congratulations again now
you have experience you're looking at a
median salary of one hundred and five
thousand dollars making more than eighty
eight percent of the
now I'm no economist but something about
this doesn't seem quite right students
are picking majors based on their career
prospects now more than ever
salaries are off the charts and
credentials quick to obtain which means
the market should be absolutely flooded
with computer science students
increasing supply allowing salaries to
fall and soon reaching in equilibrium
the problem is that demand for computer
science has grown really quickly even
compared to other engineering majors but
universities are slow if they could snap
their fingers and produce more
professors they would but the lag time
is incredibly long if you're a new high
school graduate who sees demand for
computer science teachers it'll take at
least nine years to get a bachelor's
than master's degree than doctorate and
by then things may have changed more
importantly if you can make six figures
with just a bachelor's degree working
for a company why spend five more years
only to make the same or lower salary
schools are competing for professors
with a very companies whose high demand
for graduates has created the problem in
the first place they can only increase
class sizes so much before it starts to
hurt the staff to student ratio which
lowers the school's ranking at the
University of Washington in Seattle only
a third of students who applied to CS
programs are accepted to be clear that
means two-thirds of freshman and
sophomore students who are already
accepted to the school can't get into
their desired major because it's full as
of 2017 about five hundred and thirty
thousand open jobs are fighting for
about sixty thousand new graduates a
year employees even mediocre ones but
especially the most talented among them
have most of the leverage here not only
do they always have the promise of high
salaries signing bonuses and stock
options elsewhere but because tech
companies are so concentrated in Silicon
Valley changing jobs is really easy you
won't have to move to a new state or
climates maybe not even a new house
Apple Park is a 15 mile drive from
Stanford Tesla headquarters three miles
Facebook 9 and Google 7 software
companies therefore have about the same
turnover rate as McDonagh
the average Tesla employee for example
lasts 2.1 years and 3 is considered
quite good so tech companies have to go
out of their way to make workers happy
that means free food gym memberships
cell phones unlimited vacation days
laundry bikes childcare yoga nap rooms
luxury lockers and massages Google Apple
and Facebook will even pay for women who
aren't ready to have children to freeze
their eggs still it's not enough
especially for Facebook whose poor
reputation has reportedly made it much
harder to attract talent according to
CNBC nearly every applicant Facebook
offered a job to in 2016
excepted while only about half due today
the ultimate way to keep employees
though is to involve yourself in every
aspect of their lives it's much harder
to leave a company when it owns your
house and those of your friends and
family already Facebook offers at least
$10,000 to live near the office Apple
and Google meanwhile drive employees who
live in San Francisco to work in luxury
Wi-Fi equipped buses for the employee
and the company all of these things make
sense but they often come at the expense
of the community as a whole by using
municipal bus stops to load and unload
they use public infrastructure without
supporting or improving the quality of
public transportation they've also made
housing unaffordable not only around
their campuses but in neighborhoods as
far away as San Francisco and as their
physical presence grows they begin
taking over some of the roles of
governments in 2014 for example Facebook
paid for a new police station next to
its campus along with the 170 thousand
dollar salary of an officer that should
be a red flag it's time for the country
to re-evaluate the power big companies
have over government and maybe not the
time for Facebook to try replacing the
US dollar if you were as curious as I am
about why Facebook wants to dominate
payments in developing countries like
India let me recommend watching what
Facebook knows about you on curiosity
stream if you enjoyed these videos but
wish there were more of them you'd
probably love watching their series on
technology is
this china and science curiosity stream
was created by the founder of the
Discovery Channel with all sorts of
interesting documentaries like this two
part series explaining the history of
China's Great Wall you can watch it
pretty much anywhere including PC Mac
iOS Android and your smart TV for you
the first 31 days are completely free if
you use the link in the description and
the promo code poly matter if afterwards
you decide you like it unlimited access
starts at a very affordable $2.99 a
month thanks to curiosity stream and to
you for watching this video